so here's another thing that we saw what
do we see when we're in our uh we went
to San Tan yeah what a lot times Oh
rogue one we saw rug one yeah right now
tell me the truth were you excited going
into it I knew you were he kind of
ruined my experience this guy yeah why
why tell me what well the thing I don't
like about I know you love cinema and
everything but what you do he tend to
back me up on this before you even have
a chance to enjoy the movie he reads all
the movies and then he's like oh like he
can't decide for himself I just want to
enjoy the movie experience alright so
let me ask you this then [ __ ]
yeah alright you enjoyed it I was okay
no it was it was you hated it well you
know dude five minutes into the movie he
goes and like points to scream like
Steve like and I'm like you couldn't go
like watch and he totally like his vibe
was negative yeah and it didn't help
that there's only five other people in
the theater you know that means yeah so
you think I ruined it for you no I mean
you had a little bit to do with it yeah
yeah I'm sorry can I just say something
it wasn't good the way the characters
were kind of yeah yeah yeah you don't
feel emotionally tied oh it's like the
reason why I like Star Wars is because
like the characters like Chewbacca and
Han Solo they're like dynamically oh and
r2 - it's like the character you fall in
love with the characters yeah even the
Millennium Falcon had character you know
even in the old the JJ Abrams version
right you still have the same some of
the same characters from the Chewbacca's
in it yeah right so there's a an anchor
of them smashed out even when George
Lucas tried to revive it they're
horrible movies but still you're seeing
a younger version of Darth Vader you
know you're watching a younger version
of obi-wan Kenobi so um you know but
this one's just these new characters in
this world and I we just I couldn't get
behind it they just threw menace yeah
except and then there's another thing
there's no like ability I didn't like
any of the characters like oh yeah you
like Donny in the force though I would
I had a problem with that guy - the
problem well it's like it's like he
keeps repeating the same like yeah I
know he's not but it's like there's like
I don't know it's like um you you could
use that it wouldn't stick like a
lightsaber might as well like 20
stormtroopers in that Samoan friend let
me just say something I'm gonna use this
Timon just use the rock in every movie
no no I'm I'm sowwy sure he was aboard
whatever he is it was round and big miss
U's [ __ ] the rock they used the rock
yeah because I like him
it could be anybody in it yeah just put
him in I love Diego Luna though that
vanish guy and other things maybe but
this really who's this guy hero guy is
Isis all of a sudden who night don't
ruin it for me anymore I want to watch
it just with a free mind oh yeah oh yeah
is a shaman yeah Rose I'm ed I love him
but Imperials they're not Middle Eastern
are they they can be anything right I
don't know well the main point is the
characters like not middle mister
development the writing was kind of like
even when they you know things happen I
didn't had no attachment to the
character yeah I like Star Wars because
of what I just said earlier I like yeah
it's like Yoda I like Luke I think you
guys both like was the Darth Vader at
the end that was quick
not really though Oh baby I don't watch
his back to watch it I like to figure
things out
[Music]